also Wärme deine Gesellschaft wo weiß
ich wie viel Prozent oder Bevölkerung
macht wo sie beschissen findet laber mir
mal ihre Welt ohne Geld ja sage dir zwei
Manuel ryane
Reportage lernen ohne Geld Utopia
Frage
Arbeitsgemeinschaft
[Musik]
zum Beispiel Angelina Becker totaler
Blödsinn Switzerland nichts als pur
Egoismus Claudia Monte Fußgänger nach
langem Überlegen kommen wir immer wieder
die selben Wörter in den Sinn
die haben einen an der Waffel das Herz
mit euch gemacht wie geht's
auf der Firma angesprungen also
verständlich und gut das ist kritisch
aufgenommen wird weil wir werden dir bis
bewegen
und persönlich haben
persönlich geschrieben
ja die Stimme ist natürlich schön dass
die Stimme aufgeht ja danke die
provokantisch ist Zähne ist
dazu
obdachlos ist oder sowas
Stück Freiwilligkeit drinnen ist und
John Peterson 27
Frage an Manuel welche Ressourcen kann
eine Person mit schwieriger
Vergangenheit und auf der Straße lebend
anzapfen und dies zu enden
unterstützende Freunde Familie sind
womöglich nicht da und die Ressource
fürs Geld zu arbeiten widerspricht einem
Sinn des Projekts
aufwachsen
und das heißt jede Woche klappt
hat die Ressource
und Frage ist
kriege ich auf die Ressource zurück und
mir meine Verantwortung nicht einfach
nur du bist verantwortlich du musst den
eigenen Haus haben sondern für mich gab
verantwortlich sehr sehr viel tiefer
also
Verantwortung
übernehmen das heißt verantwortlich für
meine Gefühle
verantwortlich für meine Gesundheit und
verantwortlich für meine nächste
Beziehung und das ist dazu hilft braucht
Unterstützung auf dem Markt das ist
völlig klar wir sind
auf andere Art
sehr konkrete Fragen von Doc Neo 64 450
wer bezahlt denn das Internet handy abo
Krankenkasse Stühle Audi Sache im Moment
ja ich glaube fragen
ist manche unterstützt das ganz konkrete
an dieser
Hund gefragt galt Winter oder ist
so stehen wir Ressource zur Verfügung
von irgendeiner Versicherung
und mehr mit dem aus sichtbar gemacht
für euch wie viele Ressource das una
zapft sind und wie wir das machen
[Musik]
wir möchten ein Leben ohne Geld führen
er zitiert euch meine Eltern haben
keinen Anspruch auf ihr Geld das gehört
uns sehr schön ich finde das ist ein
leichter Widerspruch man kann sich sein
schmarotze Leben auch schön reden ja es
ist schon mega viele so viel gefragt
Generationen Gesellschaft so dass viel
wertschätz über deine wovor ist groß
sind was die alles schon gemacht hat
dann mit mir heute Gesellschaft
überhaupt handelt und
gleichzeitigation hey dann mache das
Kommentar vor irus Virus HD für mich
würde eine Gesellschaft ohne Geld
bedeuten dass wir alle auf den heutigen
schwer erarbeiteten Luxus unserer
Vorfahren verzichten müssten und das
absichtlich was aber nicht der Sinn der
gewesen wäre sie hat einen Großvater
Manuel ja ihre Vision
aber das wissen wir alle also unabhängig
von dem Geld
verhalten
immer mehr
das Luxus sehr wenig mit materiell zu
tun
eine gute Beziehung führen
glücklich sie im Leben also der nächste
evolutions-
also das ist ja wohl noch nicht weiß da
gibt also
wenn ich mir Versuche vorzustellen dass
nun jeder nur die Arbeit leistet ihr für
sinnvoll hält finde ich die Ansicht
etwas naiv zu denken dass der Künstler
Bilder malt und der Maurer Häuser mauert
und beide den gleichen Ertrag erhalten
das scheint mir auch irgendwie ungerecht
zu dem vermute ich dass es nach dieser
Revolution deutlich mehr Künstler aus
Maurer geben würde und wir Sie mit den
50 Jahren alle zusammen im Wald oder
ohne Dach über dem Kopf leben müssen
oder in einer Bildgalerie im Freien wer
jetzt
notwendige für Audi das ist gut Geld
ist das nur da und es ist sehr
Raumtemperatur
ich habe eine frage also wer mit einer
Gesellschaft wo weiß ich wie viel
Prozent oder Bevölkerung
das ist gar nicht der Fall sondern ich
bin überzeugt dass es
gut die Aufteilung geht von der
Bedürfnis was man wird Menschen wirklich
in die Welt bringen
mit dem ganzen Film
das Problem mit utopieren nicht
vorstellen wie es halt in der Gegenwart
oder mit dem ganz konkreten im System
hat so viele Vorträge geht dass sie gar
nicht so weiter
sage nett 34 schreibt und auf die Frage
was Geld ist das beste Tauschobjekt
welches wir kennen ich glaubt Handschuhe
Grundfehler von menschlichen Kultur
Dusch wird immer stattfindet
in Zukunft
funktioniert aber offenbar nicht ganz
wenn ich mal solche Autos
Wirtschaftssystem
mit der Welt das funktioniert nicht
wirklich wirklich
also warum möchtest dann immer noch Geld
zu bekommen sehr auf aspermisch
schwierig vorstellen weil doch im
Privaten
gibt
zum Beispiel dass er bestimmt passiert
dann ist für mich das Größte wenn die
Person macht und sich an entwickeln wenn
sie eine Biss passiert mit der Person
wirklich das ist für mich das Größte
Führer sondern wenn das passiert wenn
die Person das gar nicht nehmen
ich kann diese Systemkritik
nachvollziehen glaube aber dass die
beiden sich das viel zu einfach zurecht
denken nicht alle Menschen haben das
Glück und werden mit gesundem Körper
geboren wie genau würden solche Menschen
in einem schenksystem klarkommen wenn
Ihr Körper oder ihre Psyche es gar nicht
erlaubt irgendeine Art von relevanter
Dienstleistung anzubieten respektive
mega viel Flag über wohl nicht entlohnt
wird was zum Beispiel Familie Mitglieder
oder es gibt Organisationen wo
freiwillig funktionieren
Freiwilligkeit und ich glaube gerade
das vor denen erwartet wird
wieso halten
er fragt am Manuel vor Miriam ward
29.82 ich würde Manuel gerne fragen ob
er mit seinem Vater über dieses Projekt
und seine Einstellung gesprochen hat und
wie das Gespräch für ihn war für den
Fall dass es nicht stattfand wenn ich es
spannend von ihm zu hören wie er sich
wünschen würde
finde ich
und
ja
und es ist für mich Auseinandersetzung
sich noch erklärt auf der Ebene
also laufen die auseinandersetzen
wir machen das Schloss zwei drei Jahren
bringt dich Lini ins Bett das hat
Vorrang
ja zum Schluss
[Musik]
positive Meldungen zum Beispiel an den
Tisch für mich ist es revolutionär was
sie tun es geht um den natürlichen
Energiefluss kein Mensch ist in
Wirklichkeit ein Schmarotzer jeder
Mensch funktioniert gleich aber viele
sind halt noch traumatisiert und xatex
18 neue Wege findet man nur heraus wenn
man etwas ausprobiert das noch keiner
gewagt hat solche Menschen nennt man
Pioniere
provokativ
vielen dank dir